- This creepy crawler
sports a fiery red pigment
throughout its body,
and it's got a temperament to match.
(whimsical music)
The Fireleg tarantula's body
is a brownish black color,
with a rich red hue along it's legs.
This spider is a mid-size
new world tarentula,
growing around 5 to 6 inches.
This particular species is easily provoked
when surrounded by other animals.
When feeling threatened, they flick off
what are know as urticating hairs,
which cause irritation
and a burning sensation to predators.
Native to Mexico, the Fireleg tarentula
prefers dry scrub land.
They are a terrestrial species often found
in burrows self made or
abandoned by rodents and lizards.
The illegal pet trade, combined
with ongoing destruction
of natural habitat,
causes considerable concern
for the future of this species.
This is the Mexican Fireleg tarentula.
(whimsical music)